holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah ah this is making
me so so angry
i just like uh okay so what does this
say now i'm getting this [ __ ] message
we restarted the round youtube is not
receiving enough video to maintain
smooth streaming i wonder what the [ __ ]
does that mean
god damn it we'll experience buffering
so suddenly my [ __ ] is poor
we got a great connection not anymore we
don't we don't
now it says pour it says poor connection
we restarted the router and everything
i wonder why it's a full connection yeah
the router needs a hard kick in the
balls
it indeed does can we please
i mean how is it looking on there it's
really it's really really shitty
yeah god damn it
but this is making me so so mad this is
making me so mad
what are we gonna do um
okay i mean i've restarted this [ __ ]
[ __ ] like two times we restarted the
is there some kind of a setting for the
camera that maybe we got it wrong
that's not the camera it's nothing to do
with the camera
some of those last two attempts wore
down steven segal's endurance yeah yeah
zach says looks okay-ish to me it's just
kind of fun somebody said long as we can
hear maybe it'll improve
over the course of the [ __ ] i don't
really know
now i'm like wigging out about this i
mean it's always
they don't receive enough video tom they
want more show shirt off
[Laughter]
girls don't forget and then mango says
looking okay at the moment looks better
yeah so maybe maybe it's getting that
[ __ ] yeah
i'm gonna do with our connection yeah
our connection must be really shitty
sounds good now audio video looks great
to me
okay maybe it's okay i think it's a
[ __ ] google problem
maybe i'm just like super paranoid now
it's like now i don't want to talk about
it well i
still want to talk about stuff but now
i'm like now i'll be like all in the
middle of something and then it'll be
like oh
get your [ __ ] together internet yeah i'm
just like we don't know what we're going
to do about today's show
i'm not having it we're just gonna have
to like talk about the [ __ ] and it's
like
if it crashes we're just gonna have to
[ __ ] do the [ __ ] over again
until we get the [ __ ] show done yeah
you know
what are you gonna say people are seeing
it on 144p
well no zach says i'm also watching at a
144p but that's just me
okay yeah uh mine is messing up and i'm
in north carolina some people said it's
fine but some people said
it's not fine so i don't know we're just
gonna do
what we can do and i mean we're not
giving up on it
we're just saying it's that camera right
yeah
what happened if i unplug that camera
put it back it's nothing to do with the
camera i don't think maybe needs a
software update
no okay everything's been updated okay
elizabeth says everything looks and
sounds fine yeah most people are saying
it looks fine some people are saying
it's buffering but a couple
most people say it looks fine maybe it's
fine i don't know is there any way to
reduce the quality so the the stream is
more reliable
probably but i don't really it's
streaming fine on my end
yeah maybe try to edit together later on
if it gets wrong but yeah it probably
will i mean i usually do that with the
um
audio anyway like if i'm because i
always post the audio and the video like
as separate things like because the
audio goes to itunes
so because we had a couple times i think
we were doing the jonestown show
i think it dropped out like about three
hours in and we had to do
you know the other hour we had to like
restart it so i just like put the two
pieces together
so you know yeah everybody everybody out
there just put it on low quality and
then it'll probably be fine
oh mango says the atf will be busting
through the door any second maybe that's
what it is i don't know
this happened so long ago i don't really
[ __ ] know it's uh
yeah so are we ready to like talk about
this now
i'm already on my second drink you guys
i'm just kidding so
he knows i just get so yeah she gets too
frustrated
frustrated yeah but i told him i was
like look i have three computers and
they're all
slow as [ __ ] [ __ ] so it's like all
day long while i'm working this is all
i'm dealing with it's just
slow connection slow [ __ ] like all the
time
so it's kind of like i'm one of those
people it's like look if i bought the
[ __ ] i want it to work the way it's
supposed to work and if
it doesn't then i get this laptop we
just bought it
like a few months ago and it's still
i don't know why i don't know why it's
doing that didn't used to do that luis
says i gave that router over the rona
maybe that's what it is yeah it's your
fault
somehow okay so we're gonna uh so we're
done with all the shout outs everything
we can pretty much start this show right
yeah let's start talking about waking up
we're popping back up
most of the audience is back now yeah
sorry about that [ __ ]
um i'm gonna talk about this is this is
the case that got voted on
yeah everybody wanted so third colts in
a row
yeah david congratulations
yeah which it's a touchy subject maybe
this is why our [ __ ] stream is keeps
falling down maybe [ __ ] atf doesn't
want us talking about it
but i really doubt they would care well
and honestly yeah
it could they don't need to [ __ ] be
there there's millions of other videos
my girl stephanie harlow did a four
right a four video breakdown of this and
each video was an hour and a half long
yeah which is how many that's six
[ __ ] hours you guys she did a six
[ __ ]
hour super detailed i couldn't listen to
olivix i didn't have time but i listened
to like the last few
few parts of it but yeah so she knows
he's never heard of this case go ahead
go ahead and uh
really go ahead and not sub go ahead
well now this happened in 1993 and if
you're not from the us
yeah maybe you weren't born if you were
young or if you were not from the us it
might not have been a bit i mean
it was a big deal in the us but it was
like a long time ago
i was in the army at the time we were in
louisiana doing a
grtc i think joint rented this training
center it was [ __ ] that was like
it was like a mock war battle of like a
vietnam it was just [ __ ]
man it was hot [ __ ] mosquitoes and
[ __ ] everywhere
and uh in between missions we came back
to the [ __ ] flight
line they had c5 galaxies and aircraft
and everything was nice because we were
[ __ ] able to like clean up change
uniforms
getting [ __ ] t-rat food and we heard
about this case it was going on at the
time and
of course you know the government is
highly [ __ ] compartmentalized
and in the army we were like what the
[ __ ] is going on here they're attacking
a bunch of christians over guns what
what the hell
and then there was they we were hearing
that there were tanks
down there or armored vehicles fighting
them
and this was before the day of mobile
devices so you couldn't go online and
see what was happening there was none of
that [ __ ] you know i mean it was just
all rumor
you know at least when you were in the
field it was all rumor you know there
were no tvs in the field
and um when we came back it was all over
and uh it didn't smell right even back
in the day
the thing about this case is there's
really no
i kind of feel like both sides are
like i'm not saying i'm not excusing the
atf for the fbi because they [ __ ] up
big time it was a huge [ __ ]
but using military terminology now
[ __ ]
that's and then you have a bunch of men
in military uniform
all jumping on one another trying to
somehow [ __ ] each other and the
situation
so somebody comes out on top and you
look like you're the hero like you
solved it that's a [ __ ]
yeah so that was a whole cluster [ __ ]
and they made a lot of mistakes which
they did admit later on and they
actually use this
now they have a whole report on it like
dudes that are coming into the atf and
the fbi they're like please read this
because this is
how you don't do it so they do
acknowledge that they
[ __ ] everything yeah uh big time yeah
but it was a it was a lot of mistakes i
don't think they intended
it to go the way it went straight
because it's looking really good
okay so maybe it fixed it go back up
check it let me see let me see i got to
move this other kind of [ __ ]
well it still says error but that
doesn't mean anything okay um
you know so but on the other hand
uh david koresh was a [ __ ]
loon and i kind of feel like
had he not taken over because this is
something before i really did a deep
dive into this case because i was only a
few years out of high school when this
happened i remember it happening but
i was kind of like more interested in
other things i guess like i kind of knew
the details of it but i wasn't real
super into it so the more i read about
this case
the more i was like you know had this
just been the branch davidians because
the branch davidians have been around
like a really long time like david
koresh wasn't
you know he he just came in like a few
years ago so it wasn't like
it wasn't like they had this big thing
so i think a lot of it
can be laid on his shoulders too because
he was such a [ __ ] whack job
and i just think it was a perfect storm
of
bad [ __ ] that was just gonna go
badly yeah no matter here's here
is here's the setup you had koresh and
the branch davidians
the way the media had was trying to spin
this is that they were on some kind of
paramilitary compound
that these people were some kind of a
threat and that they were
basically i don't know resisting the
federal government or
it was it was some [ __ ] that's that was
the narrative
well there were child abuse uh child
sexual
and a lot of people that left the cult
did say that that show was going on
yeah and david koresh admitted that some
of that [ __ ] was going yeah but let's
back up
that's happening in all churches okay
well that's happening in scientology
there was nothing the only thing that
was unusual about the branch davidians
is that they were
a christian apocalyptic
kind of a [ __ ] organization they
thought that the world was going to end
that the uh the federal government was
becoming a tyrannical empire
that they had basically kind of
become against the american people so
they went into this
defensive position in this compound to
pray and to [ __ ]
run a damn religious cult it's a
christian cult
but almost all christian churches are
cults when you really get down to it
they're little bitty churches
it's not like in europe where a church
is married to a government or anything
in the united states a church is a
private business some dude starts
and buys a [ __ ] building and hey come
on in this is my church
so
they were in there waiting in doomsday
they had a whole ideology around it
um they had a bunch of guns somebody's
asking what about the guns what's the
law say about that
every member legally possess the firearm
there's nothing
well no they had some things in there
that were not i mean they said had it
been
just no no some of the [ __ ] that they
had
um it would have been fine but some of
the [ __ ] that they had that was lie
though
i saw the weapons manifest it was a lie
the only thing in there that was kind of
unusual but it was
it was still legal from what i remember
is they had some bolt-action 50-caliber
rifles which is
they tried to make it sound like it was
some kind of an artillery pieces they
weren't
that's real common today yeah um
now there may have been a few felons in
there that that had access to weapons
but that doesn't matter because that's
even in
scientology scientology's armed to the
[ __ ] teeth
they are they got secret [ __ ] bases
out in the middle of the desert
all right um there's a lot of churches
that are armed to the [ __ ] teeth
uh but they legally own most of it and
uh you know
now there was a rumor that on the
freewinds if you know if you know what
the free winds is the scientology that
they may have had some [ __ ] red eye
missiles which was a
an infrared guided anti-aircraft
missiles that you could fire off a
shoulder
um but there's some question of whether
or not they would have been able to
legally own
that because they would have been in
international waters so they probably
could own that
there's a lot of things about weaponry
international waters and stuff in
america
i just didn't believe most of what i
heard from the feds
another thing about the child abuse
thing the child abuse that accusations
came out
after the [ __ ] debacle happened like
they used that to justify that
that is not the thing i remember i
remember okay look let me tell you
something
that's not the case i was there
i remember how it was shown to us in the
media and in the common
in the common culture of the time it
started small and then in the end
they started to say oh well they're a
bunch of bunch of bunch of child
molesters
that wasn't the case it was kind of like
the normal [ __ ]
child [ __ ] diddling that happens in
[ __ ] in in
in cults they didn't approve of it it
wasn't part of their religion but
because they're real skeptical of
legal authorities they usually hide that
[ __ ] catholic church does it
scientology does it i'm just trying to
say there wasn't really anything unusual
about branch davidians there was a lot
worse stuff
out there a lot more stuff out there
that never got it
what it really was was atf atf
trying to [ __ ] try out new weapons
and new training
trying to look good in front of the
cameras and uh
i think that's mostly what oh i'm not
denying that i'm just saying that there
had been
um some people that left the church
earlier particularly like in australia i
think they even because some of the
members were australian
i think even they went they escaped and
they went back to australia and they
tried to
get the australian government to
intervene because there was so much
child abuse and
you know [ __ ] underage kind of [ __ ]
going on and the cult and the australian
level like we can't really
get involved in that kind of stuff so
and that was like years before that show
they were allegations and evidently
that's not really what they were
what the whole thing was about the thing
the thing was mostly just about [ __ ]
show it off and
pr and politics and well and the thing
about it is that they considered it a
training mission that went bad
that's really well and the thing about
the branch davidians was that they
didn't really
seem yes they were an apocalyptic cult
in that the sense they were in like an
end time called they thought that the
second coming of christ was coming but i
kind of feel like they
would have just gone about their merry
way being a christian cult
if david koresh hadn't come along i
think david koresh who was a loon
um kind of came along and amped all of
that up
and he he knew scripture real well
and he was very talented and he was a
very charismatic showman
people liked him when he started off and
that [ __ ] over time went to his [ __ ]
head
it was kind of like a lot of church
leaders like the founders of the mormon
church as they got success they
[ __ ] went to their head they started
[ __ ] with other people's wives
they started marrying other people's
daughters they started taking
more than one well he thought he would
he said he was the second
yeah that he was the second messiah they
start believing their own [ __ ]
okay the problem was david koresh but if
they wanted david koresh he went into
town every [ __ ] day
all he had to do is just wait for him at
the store that was one thing
that and that you could bother me about
it's like yeah it's it does seem like
like i said i
there are no like heroes in this
situation there really aren't like
like david korash is a lunatic like and
the atf like
obviously went about things the worst
possible way they could they wanted to
put on a big
impressive show for their chain of
command to justify all that money they
spent on the [ __ ] budget
that's what it was it's politics you
could
most people that were in that cult said
that if you wanted to talk to david
koresh if you were fed you could have
just walked up to the compound [ __ ]
and talked to him probably
or you could have just been downtown and
just arrested him and brought him in for
questioning
but there was no reason to storm the
damn gates because
you know [ __ ] flash forward they
killed most of those people
unfortunately that's what happened and
it was a [ __ ]
it was and like i said they still teach
it nowadays too so don't be in a
[ __ ] two new
uh employees to like not please don't
yeah
and here's something else you can't you
can't oppress other people
especially if it's a people that think
they're being oppressed and they're
willing to [ __ ] sacrifice their lives
over
you're gonna start playing into a
[ __ ] dangerous game
there there was payback for this another
[ __ ] later on
a mil a military veteran uh
[ __ ] made a big truck bomb and blew
up the atf headquarters and vengeance
for this
you know and what was that uh wake up
no no this is waco no we're not what was
that called
they blew up a dead timothy timothy
mcveigh what where'd that happen
[ __ ] um that was the alfred p murrah
building
yeah what state was that the what what
town was that a long time
yeah a couple of years later mcveigh
used this for justification going after
the atf
and wouldn't they now they take this
[ __ ] they blow it into [ __ ]
out of proportion he wasn't
anti-government per se he was anti-atf
that was really what it was because the
atf had done some [ __ ] before that
yeah oklahoma that's all right oklahoma
city bombing that's right
atf did some other sorry ass [ __ ] later
on shot a dude's dog and then shot his
[ __ ] wife i was holding the baby
over some [ __ ] up on some white
supremacist compound
they weren't really they were trying to
get away from everybody yeah they
weren't great people but they just went
in there basically and [ __ ] tried to
set the dude up and they shot his
[ __ ] family
you know um the shitty thing to do
so there was a kind of a kind of and
this was the 80s this was before
this is before um uh internet
and it had gotten around that atf
threw its weight around and was corrupt
and trying to make a name for itself as
a federal agency
there were even republicans that were
referring to it as a group of
jack-booted thugs
not we're not talking about democrats
republicans were calling them
jack-booted thugs
the it's just that organization there
you know it's not as bad as it was but
well i think particularly after this
happened and like you said the oklahoma
city bombing and all the [ __ ] that
happened
subsequently because there that wasn't
the only one that was just the the one
that the famous one
the well that was the one that caused
the most loss of life
so you know so i think that after that
that was such a pr
disaster for them that i think they felt
like maybe they couldn't get away with
that [ __ ] anymore
not going to defend koresh i'm not
defending either one of them
like i said it was a huge [ __ ]
and there was just no winners on it
and it was just sad that so many people
like kids and stuff like were kind of
stuck in the compound and couldn't
couldn't or wouldn't get out yeah for me
you know having watched a couple
documentaries on it [ __ ] had
kind of lived through it at the time and
knowing the way society was at the time
koresh was a religious fanatic who
couldn't
think his way out of his own [ __ ] he
couldn't surrender not with what he
believed
and i mean if you listen to some of his
tapes if you watch
some of the video of him preaching and
stuff like that he definitely comes off
as
wildly unhinged yeah anybody he believes
it he's not lying
oh he does he believes i'm not saying
that he just uh that's what i mean he's
absolutely
and it's kind of sad because the branch
davidians prior to that
seemed like well i don't want to say
that because i'll get into that in a
little bit because this wasn't the first
time that branch davidians had engaged
in violence so we'll get into that a
little bit
but too but i do feel like him being
there
that really kind of took it in this big
time apocalyptic dirt like the world's
going to end like right now so it almost
kind of like so the atf
i don't think they realized some cults
experts like rick ross and people like
that like tried to tell the atf look you
can't
go in their guns blazing and stuff like
that because that plate well that plays
into their narrative
and they're just gonna double down and
they're gonna fight back against you
they'll kill themselves like at
jonestown
it's like you know that's we've studied
this kind of thing we know how these
people think it's like that's what
would happen and they kind of went ahead
and did it anyway but like i said it
seems like
i don't know it just seems like it was
like terrible communication it just
seems like there was poor planning
what would have been better had they
approached him in town
just a couple of [ __ ] atf guys and
played good cop with him
and said look we're not after you we
just want to make sure you're not
hurting anybody
it's that i mean to be fair they did try
to do that
but he was so paranoid he also did not
talk but yeah
he they did try to do that i would have
left him alone i mean because look what
happened
you pushed you pushed him and then cults
tend to disintegrate on their own
that [ __ ] wouldn't have lasted long i
don't think i mean like i said even
though the branch davidians as a group
and i didn't even know this like really
when until i started looking into it but
they've been around since like the
[ __ ] 1930s
yeah um you know and they'd and they'd
actually that compound where they lived
mount carmel they'd been there
since then you know what i mean yeah but
that but
that fervent [ __ ] david koresh
[ __ ] element
i don't think that was sustainable i
think he would oh definitely not
he would have tried he would have driven
most of the members out over time
and yeah and he had prior to that and
honestly some of the people that left
like i was watching a bunch i've watched
a bunch of different documentaries about
this
and there was one and there was this
woman that
left and she left before all the [ __ ]
went down she left when you know
spoiler alert when david koresh was kind
of like oh well i'm the second coming of
the messiah and
god told me that i could just have sex
with all your wives and you're not
allowed to anymore
um because i'm supposed to have 24
babies you know what i mean
so um that one was like yeah no so her
and her husband left
and then later on like after all that
[ __ ] went down they interviewed her
and she was just kind of like well she
um
uh she said yeah like kids were being
beat and sexually abused in there and
[ __ ] like that
she also said because of what happened
at the end
um she always she's like david koresh is
a coward and always will be one
so like i said there's there's no
there's nothing happy about this
everybody sucks
it's like you know the only people i
feel sad for
are like the kids that didn't have any
[ __ ] choice
you know what i mean yeah and like they
got stuck in the compound the dogs that
got shot
yeah that's all i feel about it say that
for later yeah cause what happened to
the kids is [ __ ] tragic
i mean they were all david koresh's kids
some kids did get out like because he
did let some kids out but his own kids
he's like no these are my kids and i'm
not letting them out because like i said
he'd fathered a whole bunch of children
with
various women in the cult because he was
the only one allowed to father children
after a certain point because he was
that kind of dude
juan ortiz saying i look cool with the
cowboy hat man
this is my tiger striped my tiger stripe
booney hat
it's in it's in it's in [ __ ] honor of
blaine
[ __ ] from uh predator one he said i'm
a goddamn
sexual tyrannosaurus
tila says how many people were on this
compound i think it was
maybe a right around 100 i think the
death toll
um when all was said and done was it was
76 i want to say i think it was 76
people um and several atf agents were
also killed i think four or five of them
and then a bunch of them are we did as
well
in the uh ensuing and like i said this
wasn't just one thing it was it was a
raid
and then there was a 51 day siege
and then finally like i feel like the
atf guys were getting sick of sitting
there
because they were trying to negotiate
with him and he kept like [ __ ] around
and saying hey i'll let people out if
you let me go on tv so they let him go
on tv and then like he wouldn't let
anybody out and like
you know so finally they were just kind
of like look we're sick of this [ __ ]
chick can we just please go in there and
try to get
at least the kids out and it just didn't
happen like that
yeah you gotta understand the [ __ ] that
that caress was young
and he was young when he became a
preacher and started taking over the
branch davidians
i think he was in his late teens when he
started taking over didn't wasn't he
um maybe early 20s because i think he
was
night only 19 when he joined that church
and then like some [ __ ] happened later
yeah and he was able to
charm a lot of people and the women
liked him like older women
[ __ ] liked him well we'll get into
that too that kind of
helped him rise to power in this
christian cult
it was just uh very unfortunate [ __ ]
everybody
yeah it was just a bad situation all
around like
everything that could go wrong went well
there's a lot of interviews of branch
davidians who weren't crazy who were
there
they'll tell you the whole [ __ ] story
and how they feel about it um
some people can get involved in these
religions and just like scientology
really
and you can slowly get sucked in to
believe in something that isn't true
they thought the government was coming
after them and that the apocalypse was
going to happen and they were getting
ready for the [ __ ] post-apocalyptic
world
and jesus coming back and all that
really actually kind of
basic end time stuff
it's just that they were really planning
for it and they really believed in it
and
uh koresh was like an extremist he was a
religious
zealot he was oh big time he was a
zealot yeah and like i said
i think that because this particular
branch of because like i said the branch
davidians are an offshoot of the seventh
day on venice which had been around
um you know from the 19th century but
i think the fact of him getting in there
because it was a schism there's all this
kind of
kind of stuff which i'll get into but i
think the fact of him getting in there
and him getting more and more delusional
um didn't help matters yeah and then
there's another thing
that if you're not an american if you
don't know the federal system
the difference between a state system
and the federal system
the united states is a lot like the eu
these states are kind of like
independent countries
they can ignore the federal authorities
if they want to
the federal authorities have their own
[ __ ] gig
going on and they can try to whip a
state into line and do all kinds of
things but one of the weird things about
the federal government is that it likes
to increase its budget
and because you're making money it's
it's kind of a grift
well the us has a bunch of [ __ ]
special operations units that are
sitting around and they have to justify
them
atf is one of them but then there's like
five or six
intelligence agencies that haven't
really stopped any terrorism
they don't really do anything they're
like [ __ ] jobs programs more than
anything else
so atf hadn't really done anything
that gave them good pr in a long time
and this was really just
a way that they could put on a good show
and try to check well
and i will note too that this happened
on the back of a couple of pr disasters
one of
which being ruby ridge the other one
being
they were being sued by a lot of uh
african-american
uh you know atf agents and women that
were claiming discrimination
so they were maybe looking for something
that was going to be a win and that was
going to make them look better
to the public and like justify you know
what i mean
justify their existence right that's
what i'm saying so it's like so they had
had
some of that [ __ ] in the past so you can
see like how like i said this was like a
perfect storm of like shitty things you
have to understand how ridiculous the
existence of the
uh of of of the atf is it's
alcohol tobacco and firearms they
handled
interstate taxation of [ __ ]
of tobacco there's not much there
you know i mean there's not much you
know what i mean people don't really
smoke all that much anymore um
then you had uh alcohol
uh they were doing alcohol taxation
well they also had all these swat teams
these build this this para
military wing all right so
there's no real need for that with when
it comes to raiding alcohol places and
[ __ ] tobacco [ __ ] companies
so they started to get on these [ __ ]
firearms
and the united states has something
called the nfa which is the national
firearms act that was passed in the
1920s
during the gangster era and really the
only thing
nfa laws really worry about
are if you have a machine gun you have
to register it
if you have a sound suppressor it has to
be registered
a rifle can not have a barrel shorter
than [ __ ] 16 inches
uh a pistol cannot have a butt stock
not much money there the that's not a
really good grift i mean who cares how
long your [ __ ]
rifle barrel is well if it's 16 inches
and then you
move it down to 14 inches it's more
deadly no it's less deadly
and then what you say well it's a
concealable rifle what is it
it's more concealable than a pistol no
this is it's
the whole atf thing is uh
when it comes to the firearms is
ridiculous and even the atf knows it
they've really relaxed on a lot of that
[ __ ]
right now with the [ __ ] things called
[ __ ] arm braces and [ __ ] like that
the atf doesn't give a [ __ ] how long
your barrel is
unless they don't like you if you got a
damn
if you [ __ ] let's say you have what's
called an ar-15 pistol and you put a
[ __ ] buttstock on it instead of an
arm brace
if you've now changed a [ __ ] pistol
into a rifle
and uh they're gonna want to give you 10
years or something for that it's just
it's stupid it doesn't have any it's
just regulations it doesn't have
anything to do with
reality so
if you overturn that nfa act the [ __ ]
atf will [ __ ] vanish because they're
they're just not needed anymore it's
just another
useless [ __ ] federal bureaucracy it's
a jobs program is what it is
and you can use it to go after people
you don't like that's
you know let's we're going to use these
little regulations to
go after no no this drug cartel no not
that drug cartel we've kind of invested
in that one go after that drug cartel
you guys know the deal that's all i'm
gonna say about it
okay can i actually i haven't even
started my notes yet start the notes
[Laughter]
so let's talk about david koresh which
until
i started researching this i did not
know what that was that's not his
name that's not his real name uh his
name is actually
vernon howell now he was born in 1959 in
houston texas now his mom
was 14 years old um
so i guess so she gets pregnant
his dad bobby howell
took off because he met another teenager
that he liked better
than david koresh's mom whose name was
bonnie so
he's just like bye pregnant girlfriend
who is 14.
i'm off so uh david koresh
we'll just call him that even though
that's not his real name
um actually never met his biological
father
now after his father took off like i
said his mother was very young
so and she had a baby so she very
quickly hooked up with another dude who
she thought would help her out
uh but this dude also turned out to be a
piece of [ __ ] he was a
violent drunk um so
then she gets like
you know at this stage she's you know
the kid's like four years old and she's
like look i can't deal with the [ __ ]
anymore it's like you got the violent
boyfriend you got this little
four-year-old kid you can't really deal
with it she's only like [ __ ] 18 years
old at this point
so she leaves him with uh the
grandmother
early and clark so he's with the
grandmother for three years
and then he then she marries this other
dude a carpenter
named roy haldeman who was also an
abusive piece of [ __ ]
and so they ended up having another son
together named roger he was you know
david crush's half-brother
now david koresh has has said that his
early childhood he seemed like
he wasn't he wasn't stupid he was like
actually really intelligent but he did
have some learning difficulties
i don't think they would have called it
this back then but from what i know it
sounds like he was probably dyslexic
because he said stuff like reading and
writing was like an alien language so it
was like really difficult for him so i
think he was probably dyslexic
so at school um a lot of the kids didn't
really like him plus he was real
into religion which a lot of kids
thought was weird
and so they called him names they
usually called him verney or they called
him mr ritardo
which is nice um you know so but you
know how kids are
so they called him that when he was a
kid so he ended up dropping out of high
school
in uh his junior year now
when he's 19 years old he starts a
relationship which 19
and she was 15 which uh if you're
keeping score that's kind of considered
statutory rape i guess you're depending
on what
state you're in um she ended up getting
pregnant
now he uh said that he had been born
again
in uh the southern baptist church but
then later on he joined his mother's
church which like i said was seventh
seventh day adventist which the uh
branch davidians are a
an offshoot of the seventh day adventist
which i'll get to a little bit
uh in a minute now while
koresh got all into this
new church he started lusting
after the pastor's daughter
who again was just a teenager and
apparently here's something that
happened he said that while he was
thinking about it
he opened the bible for god to give him
a sign whether this was okay
hold on i got to hear this and the bible
said and he opened it to isaiah 34 16.
and the passage saying uh none
should want for her mate which he took
as just
he's like oh well that means that i
should go get her and he's hit it
yeah that's that's how he interpreted it
because of course he did
so basically so so he thought this is a
sign from god
so he goes to the pastor and he says hey
god told me that i should marry and
pregnant your daughter
not surprisingly the pastor was not a
fan
of this idea um so the pastor was like
not only
get out of my sight but also get out of
you know don't ever see my daughter
again
and also get out of this [ __ ]
congregation you [ __ ] pervert
the so that's how well that went
so 1981 he's kind of like drifting
around
he was kind of like um just a drifter
like a hippie type dude
so 1981 he moves to waco
now at this stage he had joined the
branch davidians now as i mentioned
earlier the branch davidians
are actually an offshoot of the seventh
day
adventists now their technical name
is the general association of branch
davidian seventh day adventist
now even though the seventh-day
adventists have been around as i believe
since the 19th century
this particular offshoot or sect of them
has been around since 1955. now this
particular sect of the branch davidians
the famous one
you know that was involved in the waco
raid that was um
formed in 1955 as i mentioned by a dude
named benjamin rhoden
now the davidian the okay the general
associates this is very complicated i
know the general association of davidian
seventh day adventist was actually
established by a bulgarian
dude named victor houtaf i think is how
you pronounce it back in 1935.
um this guy okay this makes me laugh so
i have to mention it
he had written a bunch of um tracks or
like religious pamphlets or whatever and
he called them
the shepherds rod which you know make
your penis jokes now
and he wanted uh the seventh-day
adventist church
uh to be reformed so
the place where the waco siege famously
took place in 1993
the compound at mount carmel had
actually been
purchased by that dude like back in the
30s
you know what i mean so that had been
like a seventh day adventist
slash branch davidians compound for a
really long time so it wasn't just david
koresh hey i came up with my own cult or
anything like that
this was a religious tradition that had
been going on for a while david koresh
was just kind of a late comer
to it so you know i just wanted to
establish that
so they bought this compound um back in
the 30s
because they um thought that
the second coming of christ was imminent
and
that's the compound was where they were
going to like prepare for it because
they thought the end of the world was
coming christ was coming back all that
kind of like apocalyptic [ __ ] that a lot
of these kind of
christian cults believe in so the mount
carmel center goes back that far
now benjamin rhoden the guy that started
uh the branch davidians he died in 1978.
now at this point koresh he had like
started a band because he wanted to be a
rock star
kind of you know and if you see like
videos of him he like wrote all these
songs and he's like [ __ ] you know he
thinks he's [ __ ]
you know jim morrison or some [ __ ]
whatever
so he um had actually been playing
uh his guitar and singing at this mount
carmel center
uh you know of the branch davidian uh
headquarters outside of waco
now he was there for a couple of years
now in 1983 um
he started saying that he could
see the future or that he was a prophet
now no one's entirely sure
whether this is absolutely true or not
but it does seem to be that when he
arrived at the branch davidian compound
the woman who was running it lois rhoden
who was the widow of benjamin rhoden and
was at this point in her late
60s or early 70s that uh david koresh
actually
started hitting that which like i said
not judging
even though he was only 20. he was
in his early 20s and she was pushing 70
at this point
um so most speculation says that he
started a sexual relationship with her
at this
point probably because he wanted
to run the [ __ ] because he had already
started to
at this point he'd already started to
like feel like hey i'm gonna run this
or you know hey i'm a prophet hey i'm
jesus whatever
now he started so he started to say
that god told him that him
and lois who again was in her late 60s
um should have a kid which i don't know
how that's going to work because she's
in her
i mean god's better got to intervene on
that show
that's way past menopause the old tip
the old testament is rife with it
yeah okay sarah wasn't [ __ ] wasn't
sarah like
90 and all the [ __ ] kings were like
[ __ ]
they were hot on this old chick she's
like 90.
i think her name was sarah it might have
been yeah if i'm remembering my
yeah he told the king that it was his
sister instead of his wife so you know
because he was afraid he was afraid
they'd kill him and take the woman
that's my sister because they started
king started hitting the sister and then
he found out god told him somehow
he just committed adultery he's like how
could you do this to me here take all
this money and [ __ ] and run get out of
here
i i don't know that's that's some old
testament morality there
i don't know yeah if you accidentally
hit some married chick it's on you
you're now dirty you're ritually unclean
how could you let me do that that's some
[ __ ] wild [ __ ]
yeah yeah and she's 90. you can tell
dudes wrote the bible
yeah i'm just saying this is some silly
ass stories she's 90
hot as [ __ ] the kings after it
think about that that was some hot 90
year old i'm just saying maybe back in
the old days
they lived longer i guess they lied more
well yeah i think it's that second thing
let me go ahead and get this out of the
way we've had dr price on and [ __ ]
who's a really good [ __ ]
mythicist um the the old testament and
the new testament none of that is
historical
not that these are those are all just
tails tall tales
it's like little bits of history put in
just to give it some spice and make it
seem like it's a little bit realistic
well they mentioned real people
right that's what i mean they that
didn't happen just as a little
sprinkling but most of the [ __ ] in there
did not happen no no not not not in real
life no
and there was a time when i wanted that
[ __ ] and that's okay it's okay
it's just not it's [ __ ] just plagues
of egypt now i understand what it is
they had the [ __ ] red tide it came in
and then
you know killed all the [ __ ] fish and
then the frogs and then the [ __ ] you
know what i mean
and then they fed all that [ __ ]
contaminated grain to the firstborn and
they died no
no what it is is that it's like none of
that happened it was like a touhou
japanese monster movie that's what
they're talking about and it's the god
of the
godzilla the god of israel using the
gods of [ __ ] egypt like a whipping
boy for
all the world to see that [ __ ] yahweh
is supreme superior to the [ __ ]
egyptian gods
that's all it is yeah it's yeah it's
just my dick's bigger
my dick is bigger than you my gods are
better than your gods that's exactly
what it is
i mean when you look at it through that
like i said i'm not denigrating it
anyway
i mean i love mythology i love all that
kind of stuff but you have to understand
like the cultural context of the time
that that [ __ ] was written
um and everybody has a reason for coming
up with those types of stories that's
why i find them like really fascinating
to study because
you can by studying a culture's
uh mythologies you can understand what
they found
valuable yeah that's their value system
yeah so that's like and
it tells you a lot more than their
actual laws it's multi-purpose though
too it's very much kind of like the mcu
or good star wars writing it's well you
know
i don't laugh at it because i think
that's good mythology too if it's well
yeah yeah yeah
it's something for you to believe in to
help you face life and death
because you're gonna die we all die yeah
all right
and avoiding death isn't always the
[ __ ] primary thing
sometimes giving your life to for
something that will [ __ ] be
a greater good later on that might be
the right thing to do
you never can tell everything's
situational yeah situation
you just gotta go with the flow like i
said earlier yeah well they're
they were making moral judgments those
kamikazes that threw themselves in their
planes on the deck of american
air aircraft carriers you think those
[ __ ] are crazy no they weren't
it was that was a totally rational trade
from their point of view
an invading army of [ __ ] white
barbarians were heading directly
towards japan to put those big pink
dicks on those [ __ ]
girls and they had to stop that at all
[ __ ] cost
well yeah i mean you have to think in
this i think this is why i'm fascinated
by a cults and all that kind of stuff
is that because if you think that what
you're doing
is the right thing or you think that
it's for the greater good
then you can do all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] yeah all kinds which from the
outside
might look crazy crazy but everybody
like most people unless they're like
completely lunatunes
most people do have actual reasoning and
a reason for doing what they're doing
it wasn't crazy from the japanese point
of view that's what i'm saying because
they had a reason
the japanese invaded china and [ __ ]
they did something called the rape of
nanjing or also the rape of nan king
and what they did to the chinese people
was [ __ ] worse than what even
happened to the jews
all right it was worse than that i don't
know if it was
the same amount of people i think it was
less people but what they did there was
[ __ ]
horrible all right and they they took
pictures of it
and they were carrying pictures of it
and their knapsacks out there on those
islands
it's like why so they thought we were
going to do the same thing to their
women
so you know the japanese of the 40s are
not the same japanese of today
well and they were just different they
thought they were doing the right thing
i mean yeah they were laying down their
lives for their [ __ ]
family and their women back home yeah
that's what i mean and i i think that's
what makes
i mean people that history would see as
villains and i'm not saying there aren't
villains
they aren't villains because obviously a
lot of them are but
they they had reasons for doing what
they were doing
and they were understandable reasons and
maybe that's kind of like
uncomfortable for people to think about
but
they did actually have justifications
for doing what they were doing and it
wasn't always like crazy justifications
sometimes it was understandable
justifications zach's in there talking
about big pink dicks he's dick
he's dick centric yeah you just you just
made him go off on a on a fantasy
tangent yeah he's only going on a dick
tangent
well when you said that i kind of had a
very brief
well i had a brief like picture of just
like a bunch of pink dick like on
popsicle sticks yeah like that but it
was like very pretty
it's psychological warfare put the
pink dick imagery into the mind of the
audience because i mean i don't know i
feel like dicks
are not that aesthetically pleasing
so it's kind of like it is all funny i
can't believe we started out the show
talking about sounding
yeah but yes that was on you that was
your fault was it yeah it was on your
fault
everything's my fault it's a show jenny
and i'm gonna [ __ ] clown around on
the show he's gonna clown
yeah that's all right yeah um yeah so
stop you clowning around
oh my god you guys for some reason to
think of your future
yesterday when i was this is this is
what happens
i was in the shower and for some reason
i was like every now and then because i
sing to pookie all the time and i think
i've mentioned this on the show before
so i try to like insert her name into
like various songs where it fits
and i can't believe that i and it just
like came to me in a flash yesterday
morning
that i was like oh my god i can't
believe i never sang
message to you rudy with pookie in it
because it fits perfect right
and then so i thought of it and then i
told him because i started singing it to
her and he just like started cracking up
and then he's like oh my god that's
[ __ ] hilarious
and um so now i can't get that [ __ ] in
my head
i like the original they're both good
they're both good
um you know but yeah so like now every
time she comes in the room like stop
you poo cling around yeah better think
of the future
yeah let's just end up in jail i'm like
pookies not go to jail and you will
suffer
a message for you what's his name
livingstone
i can't remember you looked it up on
youtube because i know that because i
knew the specials version and then i
knew that it was a cover and that like
but i hadn't i'd only heard the the
original like oh time or two
yeah which like a reggae song um
but yeah so that's what we've been
saying to her for the last couple of
days man dj mania goes yeah it's saying
to me yeah it's a podcast
of course this is what i get getting off
on the dick tangent yeah that always
happens
well you know and i'm about to tell you
some more [ __ ] that's going to put you
on another that says i love it i just
turned this on and this is the
conversation going on pookie will never
be in jail we're never going to put
boogie in jail
well yeah
[Laughter]
people should drink more i agree we got
a pretty big crowd going on everybody
please um i walked with the pookie oh
that's a good one actually
is that a rocky erickson song what's
that i watched with the pookie like i
walked with a zombie
that's rocky erickson right you don't
know oh look tila's got a message in the
pookie
oh my god that's a good one yeah
i also thought of like goodbye pokey
tuesday but i was just like well i don't
want to feel like i'm saying goodbye to
her because she's not going anywhere
she better not be going t knows a deal t
even likes reggae
yeah yeah she knows she knows the old
reggae this is for some reason i do this
kind of [ __ ] all the time i don't know
if pookie likes it or not she
she puts up with it okay she tolerates
it
because i kind of like try to think of
new stuff all the time like to keep her
entertained
thank you victor big pink dicks five
dollars for big pink dicks
[Laughter]
in the pink dick pop in the pink dick
fun
yeah which i don't even know what we're
gonna use really straight to japan
[Laughter]
okay so you guys you guys okay so david
koresh
is allegedly hitting this
almost 70 year old woman which like i
said no judgment
um but yeah so lois who was still
running the [ __ ] at this point
she decides that she loves the dickens
so much
allegedly that she's gonna let uh david
koresh like just
say whatever the [ __ ] he wants at the
branch davidian church
so he has his own message which is
called and again we're talking about
dicks god damn it it's called the
serpent's
root because of course it is pookie went
down to georgia
how about that one looking for pookie in
all the wrong places
[Laughter]
oh my god all right you didn't even hear
what i said about the serpent's root
go ahead and say it again the serpent's
root i was a little bit out of it that
was the name of david koresh's
uh message or like the name of it well
i'm sure it probably was rude of his
serpent no he got that [ __ ] from [ __ ]
snake pliskin that's what i'm saying
no well snake plus can have the yeah
this is a shirt off
83. when snake took his shirt off he had
a tattoo
of a [ __ ] cobra coming up under his
waistband like it was his dick
subtle yeah had this been some [ __ ] from
the late 90s that he'd pulled that [ __ ]
down
a little bit so you could see some of
that dip root they'd have got rid of
that
yeah no talking about everybody likes it
in a way like the dick
root is actually kind of like sexier
than the actual actual dick just the
rope
because it's just like suggestions like
because it's just like a horror movie
it's always better when it's just
suggestion you don't see the actual
thing
you know what i mean yeah um i guess
you guessed it you're not a girl you
don't know i don't know ectoplasm-esque
what are you guys drinking oh [ __ ] i got
what are you drinking
i am drinking this is a that's a
screwdriver that's a screwdriver yeah
well and [ __ ] it's almost empty this is
my second one well and by second i mean
like
fourth because that was like i'm
drinking um
spiced rum and uh
and on top of that like it's like one
part spiced rum
one part pineapple and one part orange
yeah it's good yeah it's good real good
you're probably
not eating another drink so yeah
serpent's root that's what i was talking
about which like i said
that's what well obviously and
considering the [ __ ] that he got into
later on i'm sure like his whole [ __ ]
life revolved around his dick
so um so he starts giving these this
series of
sermons called the serpent's root some
of the people in the group were like
yeah not so much some of the people were
into it but you know the so was like a
big
controversy about it now at this point
lois as i said who was an older lady
she had a son named george rhoden now
george rhoden
also a lunatic spoiler alert um he kind
of had
planned that he was going to be the next
uh leader of the group like after his
mom croaked you know what i mean
so that's going to come into play later
on as well
um so he did not uh not surprisingly did
not like david karash because he just
saw them him as this complicating factor
he was an interloper
it's like hey i'm supposed to take over
the ship what the [ __ ] are you even
doing in here
you're just kind of like dividing the
flock or whatever
so there was like a lot of controversy
there now
at this stage david koresh who like i
said he wasn't named that yet but i'm
not calling him that because i don't
want to be too confusing
he said that god told me that i should
marry this girl
named rachel jones now i think i can't
remember but i think rachel jones
was of age um and that might be the only
time that i can say this about this
because a lot of the women that he
married
were women that he married were teenage
girls
so um but i think this girl was
18 or over so maybe it's okay just this
one time
um so he marries her
and then oh did you okay
she better be good she'd be all right
better think of your future
yeah better thank you a future we've
been oh you wind up in jail yeah we keep
talking
except that i say to her it's like
you're not gonna be in jail it's okay
she doesn't care
um so yeah so he marries this woman
rachel jones like legally apparently
now okay so at this point there is a
power struggle
between david koresh who like i said has
probably
allegedly banging lois
the elderly leader of the cult so
there's the thing between him and her
son
who was supposed to be the heir
apparently
so there's a power struggle um george
rhoden says hey
like most of the people that are in this
[ __ ] cult are all about me
so you guys need to [ __ ] the [ __ ] off
into the sun [ __ ] the [ __ ] off yeah
well you know
okay so basically um
he wasn't [ __ ] around either he like
he basically had them at gunpoint is
like get off my land [ __ ] it was
kind of like that kind of situation
so everybody that was that was david
koresh and everybody that
followed him um basically they were like
you're gonna shoot we're gonna shoot
your asses if you don't
piss off so they all pissed off
now uh it was him and um you know about
a couple dozen people that were
sympathetic to him
and they [ __ ] off to palestine
texas which was about 90 miles away
and they kind of established their own
little base camp it was kind of like a
shitty camp it was just
it was you know a real camp it was just
like [ __ ] tents and like a couple of
[ __ ] trucks and [ __ ] like that
they didn't have any water like running
water nothing like that
so uh you know they just had a couple
buses and whatnot and they lived there
for
two years now during this
two-year period where they were just
basically living out in the [ __ ]
forest
him and his two dozen followers
um he decided he's gonna go and like
recruit some new people where did he get
money to do
this i don't [ __ ] know but he goes to
california
he goes to the uk he goes to australia
he goes to israel
and he actually ends up getting a few
followers and bringing them back with
him
like i said where is he getting them
they're living out in tents and he has
money to like [ __ ] fly to australia
how the [ __ ] did that happen and bring
people back with him
i have money i guess yeah even though
he's
i mean his mom had him when she was like
14. she didn't have any [ __ ] money
where the [ __ ] you getting money from i
don't know i don't know this is
mystifying
i'm like [ __ ] i can't afford to fly to
australia and i have like three jobs
but you know what i mean so i'm just
saying so at this point um
he ended up traveling to israel and then
while he was in israel
he said that he had a vision that he was
the modern-day
cyrus like the persian king that was in
the bible or whatever
it's nothing for these people to save up
money and do [ __ ] they're passionate
collection plates they don't have
expensive tastes
they're not paying uh they're tax-free
the money goes to mostly the church you
can you can do a lot of fantastic [ __ ]
with church money
that's that's how he got there i guess
yeah
yeah maybe he stole some money from like
the old lady or like they [ __ ]
so do they just panhandle in the street
people have money
i guess religious people have money
crazy
i'm in the wrong gig i guess you
probably are
i keep saying i should probably start
well going to go on to australia and
back and this is back in the 80s
cat says cougars got money maybe 2500
maybe lowest gave himself maybe
2500 that that's not a lot
that's true back then i don't have that
much though actually less
that have been less probably more like
1500 if you [ __ ] booked it right
because it costs about 1500 in the 80s
it was about 1500 to go to brazil
okay so yeah yeah not that bad
mark says there was a cougar that called
my co-worker white chocolate two years
ago
damn you gotta tell that story that
sounds intriguing
[Laughter]
okay so at this point so he has this
vision where he thinks that he's the
modern day cyrus like i said from the
the persian king of the bible so it's at
this point that vernon howell which was
his original
name he actually filed uh to change his
name
in 1990 and he legally changed his name
to david koresh
now koresh is the biblical name of cyrus
the great
the persian king as i said uh he's
called a messiah for freeing jews during
the babylonian captivity
and his first name david he took because
again he was trying to be seen as a
messiah and he was like oh i'm from the
line of david just like all the jesus
you know what i mean
so he um took that as his name so like i
said that wasn't his legal name he
changed it in 1990
now what ended up happening so him
and his followers are living out in the
[ __ ] woods in tents and whatnot
now lois the older lady who was
you know running the branch dividends
back at mount carmel she died
in 1986. now at this point all of the
branch davidians that are living out in
these tents are like
i wonder if we could like go back in
there and like take over that [ __ ]
because
you know she's gone now and it's like
now we can have like you know we could
fight it out with her son or whatever
for power
um and it seemed like in the interim
since lois had been so positively
disposed toward him that a lot of people
that still lived at the mount carmel
uh compound started to become more
sympathetic to david koresh
instead of lois's son so as i said
there's kind of like a schism going on
so um okay this
part of the story you guys this makes me
laugh so hard
so late 1987 i love this
um like [ __ ] lois's son
he's uh george he's kind of like his
uh you know support in the group has
started to decline
so david koresh decides he's gonna come
back and like challenge him
now they have to have some way of um
solving this challenge do you know how
they did it how's that
oh my god this is so good this is so
good okay so they decide to have a
contest
over which one of them could raise
someone from the dead
they're going to raise someone from the
dead and whoever can do it
is going to be the leader of the cult i
[ __ ] love this so much this is so
hard
that's
a on the fact that they actually
believed their [ __ ]
all right they believed that they could
bring somebody back from the dead
that's what's so funny if they didn't
actually believe that they would have
never made that decision
yeah even scientologists don't do that
yeah so that tells you that they they
believe
oh oh big time they were true but that's
what makes it funny to me because they
actually really thought
that they could dig up because you guys
okay so that was the contest
yeah that was the contest we're gonna
you see who can like bring somebody back
to the dead
so what happens so george
challenges david koresh to you know a
resurrection uh
challenge contest or whatever oh my god
i love that
that needs to be a game show um so
this is how serious [ __ ] george was
about this
he exhumed a corpse i think it was from
either somebody they knew or somebody
that was a former member that had died
and they went so far as to exuma corpse
from the cemetery
and they brought it back to the compound
and they're basically like whoever can
bring
because i think her name was anne
they're like whoever can bring this
woman back from the dead is the [ __ ]
the leader of the branch to videos she's
like
the [ __ ] highlander i don't know what
it is this is really really funny to me
so who was it who were they going to
bring back from the dead like i said i
think it was a former member called
it was it was a lady like ann yeah yeah
yeah well some of the um former members
i think they buried like on the
land although they said she was in a
coffin so maybe it was from a cemetery
i'm not real sure so they actually dug
her up
yes dug her ass up and brought her back
to the compound
and are like they he threw down george
did how long has she been dead i don't
know
yeah it's like come on is she fresh
that seems like it would be harder she
wasn't fresh
i mean obviously it's not going to
matter because you're not going to
resurrect
god [ __ ] could do anything so i'd
imagine she could be years dead just
bones
and god could bring her back to bring it
back like one of those ray harry house
and skeletons
[Laughter]
that's how faithful they were i know
what that's what i don't know this just
like
i don't mean to be an [ __ ] this just
like makes me laugh so hard
that's why you don't want to go [ __ ]
with them people when they believe some
[ __ ] like that hell yeah
yeah they actually really did believe
they really did believe it
that well okay well at least george
believed it because he actually did dig
up the [ __ ] corpse and everything and
he's like hey
quresh hey [ __ ] come here and resurrect
we'll see who can resurrect and
who gets to be the like leader of the
branch davidians right
so what david koresh ended up doing
though was that hey
um here's an in i can go to the
authorities
and accuse george rhoden
of digging up a corpse because that's
like a crime yeah
so not a very strong [ __ ] you don't
get much for that though
well no but he wanted well he wanted any
kind of like in to get back in because
like i said they've been exiled
yeah so he's like well we looked that up
in other cases it's not even grave
robbery
if you don't [ __ ] steal anything from
it i think it's more like
improper treatment of a corpse yeah it's
like
yeah it's like you get you dug up you
might get fined or something but it's
not like a huge deal because i mean i
hate to be
like you know a dick or anything but
it's like you didn't take anything
from the corpse it's just it's a corpse
it's not you know
it's not like you're having sex with a
real person
or stealing [ __ ] that is valuable or
anything like that so it's not like
you know it's not like really that much
of a crime
i guess a few months maybe so but he but
he
but koresh i think he felt like oh well
this is the only way that i'm gonna get
back in there because that's
at least i can get the authorities out
here which seems like a you know kind of
a dick move but whatever
so he's like i'm gonna call the
authorities and tell him that this dude
like dug up a corpse and maybe i can get
him in trouble
so basically so he goes to the
authorities and files charges
um but the authorities were like yeah
well um
we need some proof of that like you need
to go and like take a picture of him
like exhibiting the
exhuming the corpse or like have a
picture of the chorus like we don't
believe you you know what i mean it's
like
that's kind of like minor so we don't
really want to waste our time with it
so basically so what he did and like i
said this is what i was talking about
when i said that
this whole um branch davidian thing this
wasn't the first time that violence had
erupted like within their [ __ ]
so he's like okay well here's what i'm
gonna do
he's gonna take seven of his followers
and he's gonna go to mount carmel
and he's going to get evidence of the
corpse being exhumed so he takes seven
of his followers they're all armed
and he goes to mount carmel
and not surprisingly big gun fight broke
out
because you know that's how religious
groups do they just like [ __ ] shoot
at each other
and that's that's what happened well
actually that's happened many times
well yeah that's what i'm saying it's
really not that weird
so it's all about she's not that weird
yeah that's not that weird
so yeah so they all go they're all
shooting at each other nobody got killed
or anything
but uh sheriff shows up uh rhoden had
actually been shot but it wasn't a big
deal it was minor
um he had gotten pinned down by david
korres and his followers he was like
hiding behind a tree
now as a result of this um david koresh
and the seven people that had
accompanied him on this little raid here
were charged with attempted murder um
but they all got uh acquitted except for
david koresh uh
in which case it was a mistrial but they
all got away with it essentially
so they were all shooting at each other
no charges were filed yeah you know what
i mean i mean they were but oh
no new zealand is like going what are
you talking about oh no oh no
yeah oh no am i still on
uh yeah it looks looks like it well okay
we're still talking no it came back okay
okay came back
oh shit's kind of hanging up no no no
why
why why why oh just let it go did you
should you close it
no just let it go come on